là où ça bouge au pays des devinettes il
s'agit d'un personnage il a été à la
fois architecte mais aussi designer
notamment aux 83 et lorsqu ils
réaménagent les salons privés de
l'elysée pour françois mitterrand il a
fait aussi de magnifiques photos
notamment lorsqu'il était prof de gym
ici à coutainville
il s'appelle marc aide et c'est son
retour à coutainville
à droite c'est paul hogan dit paulo à
gauche marc held di marco ensemble ils
ont créé le premier club mickey d'agon
coutainville un job d'été dans cette
petite cité balnéaire qui juste après
guerre accueille les familles de
coutances sinistrés on voit mais pas la
page ben voilà séducteur de la plage
horaire des choses j'avais une
magnifique moto java bicylindre de temps
où g chrome
j'ai vendu ma moto et j'ai perdu ma moto
pour aller à l'auto bogans veut
l'histoire incroyable c'est qu'on parte
au sens tous les deux on demande à des
confrères à combien il faut prendre la
leçon la quinzaine la hausse installe et
le premier soir les dames viennent avec
leurs petits enfants et tous le soir on
avait cette boîte de gâteaux plein
d'argent et on a commencé dans la petite
piaule dans le club ne croyais pas
laventure commune durera sept ans sept
ans pendant lesquels marc l2 fera
beaucoup de photos exposées aujourd'hui
à coutainville
il y avait une douce gentillesse une
bienveillance de ses mômes un espoir
aussi c'était avant avant les trente
glorieuses et je crois que ça alors ça
vraiment sa porte témoignage d'un temps
révolu
et puis l'autre lieu d'exposition pour
voir les photographies de marc held
c'est ici à la galerie du petit office
en plein coeur d'agon coutainville s'est
ouvert jusqu'au 4 septembre
allons au cinéma au concert au théâtre
où jean allons au contact des gens et ça
c'est très important de gens nous la vie
je trouve pas trop préparé tout de suite
quand il faut se bouger vous est
impressionnant à chaque fois dans mon
travail il se produit quelque chose
c'est toujours une sorte de
reprogrammation de ces matériaux de
guerre donc en quelque chose de
différent c'est pas forcément
l'opposition guerre et paix basiquement
laisser essayer d'insuffler une nouvelle
vie
sorte de spiritualiser ces éléments il
ya beaucoup de détournements je parle
beaucoup à du coup de reprogrammation
des armes en autre chose quelque chose
de pas forcément positif mais un autre
angle un autre angle de vue c'est vrai
que j'ai un regard très distant et ça se
retrouve vraiment dans mon travail fin
d'un beau coup dur du monde décalage en
règle générale c'est ça interpelle
beaucoup les gens l'exposition est à
voir le l'histrion d'hermanville sur mer
jusqu'au 20 août
miroir mon beau miroir dis moi qui est
la plus belle
jacques perotti a pu belge espérance
rebelles quoi
alors yoann miroir mon beau miroir c'est
dans le cadre de normandie
impressionniste pour vous l'imec
l'occasion de parler et portraits jeudi
soir par exemple qu'est ce que vous
faites jeudi soir nous accueillons
pierre assouline le chronographe
français ainsi qu'un comédien françois
marthouret pour une grande lecture
vendredi 20h vendredi un critique de
cinéma emmanuel burdeau kim avant de
nous parler de paul verhoeven et de son
dernier film elle n'est pas la première
fois qu'ils se manifestent
et puis il ya une grande après-midi
c'est samedi 15h voilà plein de choses
17 invités voilà l'abbaye est ouverte à
tout le monde aux grands et aux plus
petits donc on invite évidemment des
auteurs mais pas seulement des artistes
par exemple est un artiste plasticien
qui est capable de reconstituer les
visages des morts et il avait participé
à la reconstitution du visage d'henri iv
et v tements 3d alors plein de choses on
peut se restaurer sur place on peut
passer tout l'après midi ici toute la
soirée pour discuter biographie portrait
le seul le visage
en fait c'est le tamis et ça finira je
crois vers 23h enfin vous avez doullens
heures par un concert et vous avez tous
sur le site de l'imec bien sûr merci